when i was in the beginning of my
entrepreneurial career i would read a
book on delegation right and as soon as
i read the book i was like okay this is
how you delegate and then i would come
back to the team and be like all right
delegate delegate delegate delegate
delegate right and i'd be like all right
y'all are good and then i would dip out
and then you know we all kind of know
how the story is probably going to go uh
me being super excited about uh business
and thinking that things are gonna you
know auto things are gonna run
themselves right now that i've delegated
everything i'm a big boss man and then
of course i check in a few weeks later
and then things weren't done the way i
wanted to and then of course you know i
read super you know a bunch of books on
management etc and then i dive super far
and start micromanaging everyone trying
to control everything
and then yet again the problem would
arise where people were not doing what i
wanted them to do but for different
reasons because they felt completely
stifled they wouldn't take initiative
because they felt like they needed my
sign off and everything and then i'm
basically a huge bottleneck in the
business yet again but in a different
way
and so i say that um to illustrate uh
one of the the thinking frameworks that
has served me well and i'm actually
really excited to talk about this
because when i when i talk to people i
think a lot of people think that i'm
told that sometimes i communicate some
ideas well and so what i wanted to do
was provide you the frameworks for
thinking through thoughts and i know
that sounds crazy but i'm going to give
you four different frameworks that work
really well for me
i'll try and give you examples of each
one of them so the example that i
started with that little story right is
an example of something where most
people
try and solve how much management versus
uh you know should i delegate or should
i manage right and instead of thinking
of it as a problem to be solved it is
instead a dichotomy to be managed as in
micromanaging is not good on this
extreme and you know complete delegation
on this side is not good either way
right abdication and so there's a middle
ground and so what's interesting about
this is that um there are a lot of
different things that come up in the
business world where i will see people
conflate or mistake what thing they are
solving right and most times when i'm
talking to a new entrepreneur or even a
more established entrepreneur and they
reach out for help or guidance or
whatever right
or it's one of our portfolio companies
most times they'll start talking right
really fast about all this stuff to try
and provide context and i'll just
usually pause them and be like what
problem are we solving it usually gets
them to stop right and i would highly
advise you if you're if you're dealing
with if you have subordinates or you
have direct reports
who roll into you and they have a whole
bunch of decisions a lot of times they
can get caught and sometimes ourselves
too we can get caught in the in the day
to day the minutia and just simply pause
and say what problem are we solving
there's so many pieces of this that i
want to unpack that i think are going to
be really interesting for you but the
first one is when you define what
problems you are solving you might even
have to ask the question is that a
problem when some people are like well
hey we're getting you know customer
service complaints it's like okay
understood
is this something that we believe that
we can reasonably eliminate is this
something that is catastrophic to the
business or is this something that we
can kind of try and improve over time
you know through systems and process
right and so a lot of times people
misprioritize problems because they
perceive them as as threats to existence
when in reality they are a course of
doing business and things that we can
constantly improve right especially if
you're newer you're starting out of
course your product's not going to be
perfect yet right you're just getting
going
but you improve these things rather than
thinking i have to stop everything to
fix this problem right and so the first
frame shift is that most people think in
terms of like i have a problem to solve
rather than a dichotomy to be managed as
in these are two things that will always
exist all right i'll give you a
different example of this um actually
this will be a fun one the reason we
will probably never have people who are
all happy about a tax code is because
you cannot have both fairness
and equality equality means everyone
pays 10
fairness means the rich people pay more
than the poor people
that's fair this is equal both are
ideals and yet somehow they're not the
same thing and yet both are right and so
because of that we will always have this
conflict it's the same thing between
justice and mercy both of them are
ideals both of them are right and yet
somehow they're conflicting and so we we
we see these situations and this is why
i'm trying to hopefully give this to you
because the more i started to recognize
these patterns the more quickly i could
recognize them and then identify them
and then either dismiss them or say oh
it's another one of those right it's a
pattern recognition it's like oh you
guys are spending all this effort trying
to solve a problem that is unsolvable
this is a dichotomy that must be managed
and will never be eliminated and so
i think what my goal with this video is
if i can help you get out of these
little mental hamster wheels uh it's
been incredibly valuable for me all
right so that's the dichotomy that's
like one of the one of the things that
people will mistake they'll mistake a
dichotomy for a problem that needs to be
solved all right
another framework um that that i find
immensely valuable
is the concept of of of a continuum
versus a binary all right this is
probably one of the biggest mental
errors that people make when they're
trying to identify things this is what i
mean by that
so for example i might say i'll use a
weight loss example so people will say
something like uh i'm off my diet or i'm
on my diet right it's a very simple
thing and that's because psychologically
we like to be binary we like to label
things as yes or no but biology and
reality exists on continuums as in to
what extent did you go off of your diet
right did you go 200 calories over
overall you go 500 calories over and as
even though it is quote more difficult
to think in this way it is also more
accurate and so our brain uses binaries
as placeholders for decision making to
store data right when in reality when
you start storing all these binary
decisions they start adding up and you
start getting more and more unaccurate
if that's a word on your decision-making
process because you're actually basing
your decisions not on facts but based on
binary shorthand that your brain saves
and so that is one of the biggest
mistakes that i see all the time in
thinking in entrepreneurs and really in
anything in general because we like to
have that shorthand it is easier right
it's easier to say i fell off my diet or
i am diabetic when the reality is it's
not whether you are a diabetic it's how
diabetic are you right kind of
interesting i stole that from dr cashy
but i just love that um who's my closest
friend he's a biochemist and we talk
about this stuff all the time point
being if you can think about this within
um i'll give you i'll give you a
business example so if we have a a
binary where people are saying yes or no
which is
let's say
facebook doesn't work marketing doesn't
work i hear these statements all the
time and you may laugh at this right but
i get dms like this all the time
facebook doesn't work for me marketing
doesn't work for me like you can't sell
this way in my business right and so
people want to shorten a problem into
yes it works no it doesn't work when so
much of business and problem solving is
understanding the nuance between where
we're starting and where we're going and
it's to what extent
has facebook not worked right where is
the fall off right it is not that it
doesn't work it is just we only got it
to work this percent right now we need
to get all the way over the hump to get
there but it's to what extent and i
think that when i when if you if you can
ask the right questions if you can see
the problems as they truly are they
become far more solvable and so this has
been probably i just gave you two of my
my best frames that i think with all the
time all right so i'll say these again
so the first uh mental lapse i'll say
that i see all the time
is mistaking a dichotomy that needs to
be managed for a problem that needs to
be solved people do this in their
marriages as well right so you look at
your wife right you look at your wife
and you're like i need more variety
right but later you're like i need more
consistency and you're like we have to
figure this out we need variety we need
consistency it's like yes you need both
right and so it's not a problem to be
solved the dichotomy to be managed so
that's framework number one
the second framework between two things
that i see as a problem that most people
make is that they use a psychological
binary to make a judgment and say yes
this works no this doesn't work or yes
this is this way or no that's not this
way so that i can apply this arbitrary
label that was made up
when instead it is to what extent
right it is a continuum i did not go off
my diet or stay on my diet it is how far
off did i go and a lot of times when we
do that we also can stop the the mental
judgment of being terrible people
because we can actually approach reality
which is i was 10 over yesterday so i
can go 10 under today and be fine and be
on track with my goal rather than oh i
was off i might as well eat 19 pizzas
because i'm off because that's the
psychological shorthand the
psychological binary of yes or no and so
those two understandings have
underpinned a lot of the breakthroughs
in terms of how i think through things
that have served me well and also when
talking to entrepreneurs and they're
trying to figure out what is wrong quote
wrong with their business when in
reality even naming it as a problem
might actually not be the case when it
is actually a dichotomy that needs to be
managed or they're labeling a binary
when it really is a continuum all right
and so if you look at the problems that
come up in your life whether they're
personal whether they're physical
whether they're where they're
business-wise if you look at just with
those two lenses first and and me
sharing this like these are the things
that like charlie munger talks about
having a latticework um of mental models
like how are the you know and he checks
through decisions with mental models and
so i want to share as many of those as i
possibly can with you guys because i
think um if we can think if we can be
precise with our language we can precise
with our thinking if we can ask the
right questions we will get the right
answers if you ask stupid questions you
get stupid answers if you play stupid
games you win stupid prizes and so my
goal for everyone here in mozi nation is
that uh we do not play stupid games and
not win super prizes but instead um get
exactly what we desire so that we can
then ask the bigger questions of life
and so anyways my name is oxford mosey i
own acquisition.com we do 85 million a
year in portfolio revenue i have
absolutely nothing to sell you if you
enjoyed this video hit the subscribe
button if you didn't i still love you
either way lots of love and i'll see in
the next video bye